I want to spend just one moment
um going through a few clips that are
all of my pillow CEO and founder Mike
Lindell this isn't really about Mike
Lindell in particular but this is about
the sort of psychosis that seems to have
Afflicted so many on the right over the
last week as Republicans failed to win
winnable seats in the House Senate and
governors races Republicans are going to
take control of the house they will not
have control of the Senate and they lost
some key gubernatorial races take a look
at this Mike pillow was at Mar-A-Lago
yesterday for Donald Trump's
announcement for 2024.
he is now saying I have the proof carry
Lake really won the governor's race in
Arizona she didn't I have the proof that
Blake Masters really won the senate race
in Arizona he did not how long are they
going to do this how long are they going
to tell the exact same stories for which
they have no evidence it seems like it
is Years Years listen to this
everything that was
not we caught it our caught and this is
gonna just the hip of the sphere for
unraveling see there's n's and tens of
thousands of Sinners that are looking
for a place to reach out they're going
to do sworn affidavits of what happened
remember affidavits are not evidence
they can be accepted as claims
that are still evaluated like testimony
affidavits are not evident strictly
speaking I don't think
can you imagine a new election in
Arizona there's going to be no new
election Steve bannon's already talking
about decertification or prevention of
certification again there's no such
thing carry leg lost Blake Masters lost
more people voted for their opponents
that's what happened just for Gary Lake
remember they took Mark finchams to they
took Blake Masters they were all stole
and I don't care they were stoled they
were stalled folks doesn't matter what
anyone says we already know this we were
watching it from the Edison report we
were watching it cyberly and cyberly
they were they stoled cyberly think of
it we are watching just blatantly the
citizens raw watch so you have imagined
having three different camera angles of
a crime when you have a crime of this
magnitude committed you can't certify
this election yeah folks this is part of
why they lost in 2022. I I don't want to
say that the sole reason Republicans did
so terribly was their insistence on
Election denial but to some degree
certain candidates harping on it was
stoled as pillow says did not help them
this is now a religion it's not it's no
longer well we think 2020 was stolen no
now it's we think 22 was stolen we
believe they're going to steal 2024
unless we win in which case we zip our
lips and shut our mouths here's another
clip of pillow losing the little bits
that were that are left of his mind I
guess as the Kerry Lake results came in
this guy is very unwell
what she has then was an image uh all
the images before they came in and did
The Trusted build so these uh these
teams uh these team of uh experts cyber
guys everything yeah first seven months
now have uh there was that came out with
the first report the second report this
is the one we've all been waiting for
because this shows actual machine
manipulation it shows it shows the
manipulation not just that they can be
manipulated but that our 2020 election
was deleted he has no such evidence and
he has never presented it it has been
two years now it's manipulated
um all these things and and not just
that but they also the election another
election they had in uh in Colorado so
you have two sets of proof there and
there's no proof excited Steve because
it's Vindicated it's here it's over the
uh these guys are guilty and and these
uh when these so you're if you when you
see these uh the credentials these guys
have by the way we put it up on praying
speech exclusively you can go there and
view this report and and the stuff that
backs it up where they got the stuff
from and uh so I looked for it there is
absolutely no proof there you know if
Mike pillow came forward and said you
know what
I was wrong
I don't have the proof I I don't have it
and even if I suspect that something was
was amiss
I don't have any of the proof I claim to
have I'm sorry I'm sorry for what I did
I would actually respect the guy to some
degree uh Mike uh pillow also yesterday
at Mar-A-Lago
with the completely and obviously
incorrect claim that today Ron DeSantis
would be endorsing Trump for president
we're halfway through the day more and
DeSantis has not done that here we are
live at Mar-A-Lago look at all around
the world I just had a ball with them
almost all of them they asked me about
Ron DeSantis running against Donald
Trump and I said after tonight Ronald
just endorse him in the morning you
gotta believe that why would you want to
waste all that time energy money and
everything else so very exciting here
and another one of Mike pillow's
predictions that obviously isn't coming
true unless in the next few hours Ron
DeSantis decides to come out and endorse
Trump for president I don't believe
that's going to happen and if you if you
allow me to bet on that I'm not a
betting man but I would bet on that we
are going to take a quick break make
sure that you are following us on
Instagram at davidpackman show all of
these clips we played are on our
Instagram after this short break we're
going to look at polling we're going to
look at the existing campaign for being
Trump's vice president there's really
one person right now who's uh in the
middle of that campaign and that's
Marjorie Taylor green and so many other
things